الامر الثالث وهو ما يخص بيت فاطمه انا
عندي صحه عندي من اكثر من
ثمان طرق تقريبا طبعا من حيث الاطلاق هناك
يمكن اكثر من 30 طريقه من حيث القصه ا
محاصره بيت فاطمه والتهديد بالحرق وربما
الاقتحام وربما الاقتحام هذه تقريبا ثابته
الزيادات من كسر الضلع من كذا لم تثبت
عندي لا انفيها ولا اثبتها وان كان نفيها
عندي قد يترجح
لكن التهديد هو يكفي التهديد بالحرق
ومحاصره البيت والناس في عزاء فاطمه في
عزاء ابيها و وايضا يعني كانه اقامه الحجه
ايضا بقاء اهل البيت في بيوتهم عندما لم
يجد الامام علي ناصرا من باب ابلاغ الحجه
انه نحن اعتزلنا وكذا ومع ذلك اتونا في
بيتنا واقتحموا بيت النبوه او على الاقل
هددوا بحرقه وكذا الى اخره ما يليق هذا
فهذا يعني طبعا لي بحث في بيت فاطمه لكن ا
لا ادري اظن حتى انه منشور في الويب لكن
بحاجه ان اعيد صياغته وان ازيد ما فاتني
وان انقح وانظر واحتمل كثير من الاشياء هي
احتمالات
القطعي نعم
الصحيح انهم حاصروا وهددوا بعد ذلك الباقي
التفاصيل
هل اقتحموا ما اقتحموا ماذا جرى ماذا؟
هذه التفاصيل
هي يعني كما قلت تعطي تعطي الخبر نسبه هذا
النسبه وهي قناعات في الاخير من بحث
سيجد ما يترجح عنده ما لم يترجح ما يتيقن
ما لم يتيقن وهكذا بالنسبه للقصه هل
تتماشى مع شجاعه عالي ام لا اولا القصه لم
تروى جميعا
يعني اولا مثلا ا
على افتراض على افتراض ان الامام علي كان
في الدار هو والزبير والعباس وبني هاشم
واعطيت الحجه للمهاجمين بان تكلمهم امراه
وهي بنت النبي عليه الصلاه والسلام وتقول
لهم لا لا تدخل
يكون ابلغ
في اسقاط الحجج من ان لو يناديهم شخص رجل
ليش
لو ناداهم العباس او علي او الزبير غير
يليق به ان ينالي من وراء الباب من انتم
وارجعوا وكذا نحن فلان وفلان وان الرجل
يخرج طيب خل المراه تنادي وهي بنت رسول
الله وبقيه رسول الله وبضعه رسول الله خل
تكون الحجه ابلغ
لما
لم يرجعهم هذا
وهددوا بالحرق حتى قال بعضهم حتى وان كان
فيها فاطمه قالوا وان
الله طيب خليهم في التهديد هذا وبعد ذلك
ماذا؟ ربما ما عرفوا انهم سيتجرون على
ثم اقتحموا افترض نواصل الروايه انهم
اقتحموا وتلابشوا مع اهل البيت قام الذين
في البيت اقصد اهل البيت بالمعنى العام
هنا علي والزبير والعباس ومعاهم قاموا
وخلاص هؤلاء الكثير الذين خارج البيت ولما
علم الامام انه فتح الباب وكسر وكان البيت
الباب صغير يعني و وبابئي يعني تدفه و
تضربه بقدمك ينفتح فكانت خلف الباب وعلمون
ذهلوا قاموا
تصارعوا معهم كسر سيف الزبير ا اخذ علي
والزبير
وذهب بهما الى كذا يعني قبض طبعا ليس ا
ليس الامام علي هنا
مكلفا
من النبي ولا من الله بان يقاوم
مقاومه قتال الا اذا وجد ناصرا كما في
روايات اخرى قال في سلام ديني في سلام
دينك عندما احاديث الحدائق وغيره
وحتى في بعض الاحاديث عند الشيعه تدخل ضمن
هذه الاحاديث السنيه مثل اذا وجدت ناصرا
والا مامور بالسلم
يعني المواجهه السلميه حتى المداففه
بالايدي وكذا هي سلميه
اما يعني ليس فيها قتل
انا الفهم اريد اخرجهم من بيتي وهم كذا
وتكالبوا علي و
امسكوا مجموعه جيش لست لست مطالبا ان تكون
اشجع من
البقيه
ربما
طبعا الزبير هو الذي فقط اشهر سيفه
معي لم يشهر سيفه
والعباس ما اشهر الذين كانوا مع سلمان
ايضا
طيب
الان انا اسقطت الحجج يعني انا افترض اني
انا مكان علي بن ابي طالب وص النبي بعد
الغدير اذا ما ادعوهم طبعا دعاهم للنصره
ابوا او تمنعوا قالوا هذا امر انتهى و ما
نريد يعني تواكل والانصار وغيرهم وذهب عند
الانصار خاصه اما المهاجرون كان معه
الزبير
المقداد الكندي من الملحقين بالانصار معه
حذيفه وعمار وابو ذر
او ملحقين لا ابو ذر ملحق بالمهاجرين
لكن ربما بيوتهم بعيده يعني ربما ما يعني
هو جمع جمعهم قبل
امروه يعني بالنص قال دئت الي غدا وحلقين
الرؤوس فلم ياتي الا ثلاثه او
اربعه حتى عند الشيعه انه عمار حاص حيصه
ثم رجع يعني ربما ذهول في البدايه ثم رجع
يعني ثم رجع الى الامامه علي تمام
طبعا لما يرى ما لكم عدد خلاص انطلقوا الى
انا سابقى في بيتي اسجل موقفا ضد هذا
الوضع السياسي الجديد تمام
لما سجل الموقف هذا بانه خلاص اعراض
ما اخرج لهم ولا
طيب حاصر البيت اقول
بنت بضعه النبي قول لهم لا يدخلون
طيب افترض ما توقع انه سيدخلون او انه قد
علم ربما النبي قد اخبره انه اترك لهم
المجال الى هو لابد تفاصيل هذا حتى عند
البيت يعني لابد ان تكون النبي قد بلغهم
اترك لهم حتى ينفضحوا تماما بمعنى انه
سقوط الحياه والاخلاق والدين واداب
الاستئذان وكذا خل هذا حتى يستطيع ان ان
يصحوا من اراد ان يصحوا هذا في الابتلاء
تقريب في الابتلاء والتمحيص حتى لما ليش
قلت بعض الاشياء ما استبعدها حتى لو تم
الضرب ووسط اللبشه هذه كلها وما كان علي
قاع الوقت لا صارت معركه داخل البيت بس
افترض ان العل كبير وفيه من ضربها ومن كسر
ضلعها ومن اسقط جنينها طيب هذا هذه نهايه
هاجموه داخل البيت وضربوا زوجته ابنه رسول
الله واقتادوه كما قال معاويه الجمل مخشوش
فقال الامام علي اردت ان تذم ف لعمري انك
اردت ان ان تقدح فمدحت
واردت ها ان تمدح فذممت يعني
قادوه والناس يتفرجون في المدينه اقتادوه
الى الخلافه هو رقم واحد اراد ابو بكر ان
يعني السيناريو الذي جمعته من اكثر من ان
يبايعه فابى
فاكتفى ابو بكر بان اجرى يده فوق يد علي
وقال هذه تكفيني
تمام
ا فيما بعد صارت مصالحه بعد موت السيده
فاطمه صارت مصالحه لكن ايضا في اعتقادي لم
يكن هناك بيعه حتى ما روي انه بايع بعد ست
اشهر لا هذه مصالحه مصالحه حتى ترتفع ال
ترتفع ال يعني خلاص
نشوف المشترك فيها وتبقى المظالم عند الله
طبعا مساله انه هل تتفق مع شجاعتك الامام
علي ايضا ا في اشياء ممكن ان تطرح على
النبي نفسه هل يليق بالنبي مثلا ان يرمى
بسلا فوق راسه
ولا يرد هل يليق يعني ممكن ان يعني
الناحيه الايمانيه لها تعامل اخر النفس
الايمانيه تذهب بامر الله بمعنى يوم مثلا
يوم الطائف هل يليق ان النبي يرموها السف
ولا يرد عليهم هل يليق ان حتى ذكر في بعض
السيره ان عن النظر بن الحارث او عقب بن
ابي معيط انه وضع قدمه على ا رقبه النبي
يصلي
طيب لم يؤثر لم يؤثر رد من النبي مثلا
يعني ربما دافعه كذا بس قد ياتي واحد
ويقول هل يتفق النبي اشع من الامام عليه
هو اشع البشر هو يقينه بالله طيب اذا كان
مامورا بالدفع الخفيف ليس بالمقاتله
بالسيف مثلا ليس مامورا بالسيف
وايضا وجد في
ا جماعه لوط عليها السلام لما طلبوا ضيفه
وقال هؤلاء بناتي هل يليق به ان يعرض بنات
لماذا ما
دعا عليهم ما اخذ سيف وكذا يعني احيانا
فيها اشياء تطرح قضيه الامام علي يعني
قريبه من هذه القصص التي جرت للانبياء
يعني يحيى و
وزكريا ذبح ذبحا
يعني ما نقلت عنه مقاومه طبعا لابد ان
تكون هناك مقاومه وتمنع لكن ليس المقصود
ان ان الشخصيه الايمانيه اذا كانت ماموره
في ان تصبر ولا تشهر سيفا واغلق عليك بابك
والى ان يظهروا الى ان يبدوا منهم الى ان
يتبينوا للناس الى ان يسقط كل حجه الى الى
الى ما فم
لا لم لا لم يعني ليس هناك امر الهي بانه
جاهدهم وحيدا
تمام
ولا امر الهي بانه ا يجوز ان ان تامر
فاطمه ان
تسال من بالباب او تكون انت ربما حتى امر
النبي تاخر دعهم كما قلت لتسقط جميع الحجج
لكن السؤال هل يليق بشجاعه الامام علي؟
النبي ايضا جرت له قصص
يحيى وزكريا جرت لهم قصص لوط جرت له قصص
فهناك قصص في الانبياء ا تدل على انك
حتى لو كنت شجاعا
لعلك مامور باشياء تدبيريه من باب التدبير
لالقاء الحجه لسقوط الحجج والى اخره
ولا ندري ماذا جرى يعني حتى لا ندري بعض
التفاصيل
في احتمال اخر بعض الناس يقول لم يكن علي
موجود وقتها في في بيته
بعض التفاصيل تقول كذا بعض التفاصيل تقول
انها ثواني بسيطه لا تظنونه ان جالس كذا
مثل انا موجود يقول افتحي انظر بالباب
وذهبت ارجع ما في احد وكذا فتح الباب فجاه
وضغط عليها ودخلوا الجنود وصارت لبشه ما
يعني القضايا يعني فيها احتمالات عده وهي
غامضه اصلا الحادثه غامضه كثيرا
وانما استكملناها من بعض الزيادات الشيعيه
في بعض الروايات التي تبترها الروايات
السنيه حرجا حرجا خوفا ما يعني من العامه
من كذا ما ندري وجدته ايضا في موضوع هذا
ان علي مامور من النبي بالصبر
مامور منه بالصبر
مامور بكف اليد اذا لم يجد ناصرا
قال في سلامه من ديني قال في سلام من دينك
يعني انت لا عليك يعني حتى الامام علي
لعله يعني لعله يخشى ان يلحقه اثم في هذا
السكون والسكوت فسال هل انا في سلامه من
ديني اذا حصل قال نعم في سلامه من دينك
حديث الحدائق انه الصدور
ما مر بحديقه من سبع طرق مرويه في مصادر
السنه وقد اظن كتبت عنها في تويتر
انه كان يمر بالمدينه بحدائق فلما راى فلم
عندما يرى علي حديقه يقول له النبي لك في
الجنه احسن منها حتى مروا بسبع حدائق ثم
احتضنه النبي واجهش باكيا فالامام علي
استغرب لماذا يا رسول الله قال ضغائن في
صدور اقوام لا يبدونها لك الا من بعدي
قال في سلامه من ديني قال في سلام من دينك
طبعا كلمه في سلام من دينك هذا مختصر
السنه لكن في في المصادر الاخرى الزيديه
والشيعيه اظن هم استكملوا هل اجاهدهم
فقال لا قال في سلام ديني في سلام دينك
يعني في وصله كذا قطعت
لان السنه يعرفون انه ليس المراد اهل
الجمل وصفين لان علي قد جاهدهم
تمام فحذفت
المجاهده هذه وابقيت في سلامه من ديني
ال فالقضيه هنا طبعا هي حجه للامانه هي
حجه على الامه الغدير ويوم فاطمه ويوم
الرزيه ويوم
اختصام في السقيفه مع ان النبي لم يصلى
عليه بعد ولم يغسل ولم يكفن ولم يدفن هذه
كلها حجج وبراهين عاليه جدا يعني كانها
لكشف
للابتلال التمحيص لكشف الناس من الذي من
منهم يعني تبقى فيه حراره الدين الاولى او
حتى المروءه والفطره العربيه العاديه ليس
يعني تصور تصور انه لو كانت في الجاهليه
لثار الناس لخاصه وان الخزرج والانصار
كانوا حلفاء خاصه الخزرج هم حلفاء النبي
عليه الصلاه والسلام حلفاء بني هاشم من
ايام
ربما لو كانت جاهليه لما تجراوا فهنا بيان
بانك
بانه بالاسلام الخفيف قد ترتكب ما هو اعظم
من الجاهليه
يعني تصور زمان في القبائل مثلا ما احد
يستطيع يدخل يدخل البيت بس اذا اتى
الاسلام الخفيف الاسلام الشكلي ترى ممكن
يجرؤون به يفعلون اي شيء وهذا معنى قول
الله عز وجل ومن اظلم مؤمن من افترى على
الله كذبا يكون اكثر ظلما
التدين الخفيف
يدفعك للجراه اكثر من الكفر الصريح
ولذلك الله في القران عندما قال اولئك هم
الكافرون حقا ذكرها في حق مؤمنين في حق
ناس يؤمنون ببعض ويكفرون ببعض
يؤمن بعض الكتاب ويكفر بعض يؤمن بعض
الايات ويكفر بعض الرسل ويكفر بعض هذا
يعطيهم البعض الذي يؤمنون به يعطيهم طمانه
لانهم ممثلون لله يعطيهم جراه بينما
الكافر الصريح ما عنده شيء يستند عليه في
الظلم فتبقى معه المروءه والفطره وما اشبه
ذلك
فينبغي
فهم هذه الامور
و وهي من الدقائق جدا التي يجب ان تفهم
وهذا معنى قوله عز وجل معنى قوله عز وجل
يا ايها الذين امنوا امنوا الم يان الذين
امنوا ان تخشع قلوبهم وقد اخذنا نا
ميثاقكم اخذنا وقد اخذنا ميثاقكم وايات ان
كنتم مؤمنين وايات التسليم وطاعه الرسول
وكذا و والتهديد باحباط الاعمال عند رفع
الصوت فما بالك بما هو ابلغ من رفع الصوت
عند النبي والتقدم بين يديه اشياء كثيره
جدا لماذا اميت
اميت هكذا مثل ما اليوم عندهم يعني
سبحان الله صارت هناك رموز ابلغ من هذه
النصوص ابلغ من النبي ابلغ من اهل بيته
ابلغ هذه مشكله هذا ابتلاء ما يبتليك الله
بالواضح في في الواضح في السوء والفساد
وكذا لا يبتليك بالملتبس ليرتقي فهمك
وعقلك في التحليل وفي وفي الغوص على
المعنى الباطن للايمان الذي يريدها الله
وعلى عدم الاغترار بالايمان
الخفيف او الاسلام الخفيف او الاسلام مع
مرض قلب او مع ا او عباده الله على حرف او
كذا فيه معاني كثيره ذكرها الله في القران
فيها ايمان بس مختلط بمرض قلوب بارجاف بحب
للدنيا بطاعه للساده والكبراء بعباده
الهوى بطاعه الاحبار والرهبان بالتقرب من
اهل الكتاب
بطاعتهم ب ناس شكوا ناس امنوا ثم كفروا ثم
امنوا ثم كفروا في خليط من الفئات في
القران الكريم اين هي
يعني اميت وهي قد تحكي عن هذه المراتب
الايمانيه انه يجب ان تكون في مستوى عال
من الايمان ولو انتهبلها لها ولو انتبه
لها المسلمون وحققوها لما لما كان ما كان
هنا
ما حكم المهاجمين
ما دام صحت الحادثه يتوقف على على ما تم
هل تم بالمبالغه التي ذكرت يعني هل وصل
الامر ا
يعني الى اعتداء جنائي على فاطمه الزهراء
ام لم يصل ام هي هل هي هل هي الزيادات هذه
من الضغط وكسر الضلع والضرب
هل هي من زيادات الشيعه ام هي من اخفاءات
السنه
هذا علامه استفهام كبيره
يعني هل الحصار
حصار البيت اذا صح حصار البيت
والتهديد بحرقه
ا عند هذا الحق عند هذا الحدث توقفت
الروايات السنيه الصحيحه في روايات سنيه
اخرى لكن غير صحيحه يعني تضيف انه تم
اقتحام الدار وتم كذا طيب هل لها قرائن
طيب هل هل من حاصر وهدد يصعب عليه
الاقتحام والاعتداء
طيب الامام علي هل كان
بوصيه من النبي يريد ان يسقط كل شيء من
هؤلاء ام ان الامر فقط توقف فعلا عند
الحصار والتهديد لتاويل
تاويل اجتهاد لضعف علم لضعف فقه وتمت
المعالجه وتمت بعد ذلك الندم
والاستغفار وكما نعرف من بعضهم ليتني كنت
كذا ليتني كنت شجره لم تعضد ودت اني لم
اقتحم بيت فاطمه حتى هذا اللفظ هذا في
حديث لم اقتحم ولو ولو اغلق على حرب هذه
من القرائن على انه حصل اقتحام لكن هذا
الاقتحام ماذا جرى فيه؟
لن يقف هؤلاء جالسين لكن قد يقاومون بس هل
مقاومه بالسيف
هل هم مامورون بالمقاومه بالسيف ام
المقاومه بالتدافع
استنهاض اولي الهمم منهم اتقوا الله يا
جماعه وكذا
هل ماذا جرى بالضبط؟ هذه فيها غموض وهي
منطقه حرجه عند السنه الشيعه رووا لكن هل
رواياتهم
هل هل فيها تزيد نتيجه ال
هل فيها تزد هل فيها زيادات خاصه وانها
معظمها يعني في انقطاع وفي كذا وفي ام
انها
ذكرت المسكوت عنه هل زادت ام نحن كتمنا
يعني هنا الجدليه طيب هو في الاخير الامر
برمته
حدث لانبياء سابقين للنبي عليه الصلاه
والسلام حدثت احداث مشابهه ولا يسال اين
شجاعه فلان لانه قد يكون الشخص مامورا
بالسلميه بالدفع السلمي
وليش ليبقى الابتلاء
ليبقى التمحيص
كشف الموجود وكشف اللاحقين كشف الموجودين
وكشف اللاحقين وحتى الموجودين قد يكون
بعضهم تاب قد يكون بعضهم اصر قد يكون
بعضهم ا ما تدري في فيه غموض كبير طبعا
حتى رؤيه عن بعضهم انه اقتحم وفيه حتى
قنفذ هذا قنفذ ابن عمير التيمي الذي قيل
انه ضرب فاطمه بالصوت ا هذا عجيب يعني
لماذا
لماذا ولاه على جده ولا ابو بكر ر على جده
يا اخي هذا ذكره ابو طالب في لاميته وهو
يذمه كان مذموما منطلق بعدين وصارت له
صداره الى جده والي على جده
كان اسمها جد جده وجده جده بالكسره لفظ
محدث وجدت في تاريخ خليفه بن خياط اظن ان
ابا بكر ولا على جده قنفذ بن عمير التيمي
هذه من الاشياء التي حقيقه ازعجتني يعني
جلس علامه استفهام يعني الذكر ذكر انه في
يوم الدار ضرب فاطمه طيب يولع هل هي
جائزه؟ الله الله انا ترى اتعب تحسب اني
لا اتعب في البحث انا اتعب انا ما اتمنى
ان يثبت على ابي بكر وعمر شيء ولا الحادثه
تمنيت انها حدثت ربما بعكس الشيعه يتمنون
ربما الاخوه الشيعه يعني نتيجه لهم موقف
كما تعرف يتمنون ثبوت ثبوت ثبوت بس انا
اجد من خلال البحث اجد اشياء اتالم لها يا
ليتها ما بس ماذا نفعل ايضا ليس من لعله
من الاختبار لي انه هل اغطي كما يغطون
وخلاص وخل اهم اني ادرس اضع علامات
استفهام
طبعا في الاخير حساب الجميع عند الله حساب
السيئات والحسنات وكذا نحن لا نتدخل في
لكن علينا بما تبدل لنا في الدنيا
بالاضافه الى قرائن كثيره ان الخلا يعني
في قراء ما تفهمها بعد غدير يعني سواء
محاوله اغتيال النبي في هرشه او يوم
الرزيه او التخلف عن جيش اسامه او
الاستيلاع المنبر او الاسراع الى السقيفه
او انكار وفاه النبي او اللد او كذا قصص
كثيره في في فتره قصيره جدا يعني شهرين بس
من الغدير الى وفاه النبي وحدثت كل هذا ثم
بعدها يحدث ايضا ال ا الهم بقتل سعد بن
عباده او امر امر عمر بقتله يقتل سعدا
فانه صاحب فتنه و ا مهاجمه بيت فاطمه و
حتى التشاور في قتل علي حدث وحتى احمد بن
حنبل راؤيت
له ثم قال لا تعجبني هذه الاحاديث حديث
لا تفعل يا خالد يعني كانوا قد تشاوروا
ماذا نفعل في علي ف يعني حتى السنه رووا
هذا انه ارادوا قتله في وقت صلاه الفجر
بعد ما يتسلم ابو بكر ثم ندم ابو بكر وقال
لا تفعل يا خالد ما امرتك وهذه رواها
السنه هكذا لا تفعل يا خالد ما امرتك يعني
ما ما ذكروا القصه فلما فهم اياها احمد
كما في السنه الخلال قال لا تعجبني هذه
الاحاديث طبعا لسنا ملزمين بمزاج احمد نحن
ملزمون بالبحث التاريخي هلجره
يعني بالاضافه الى قصص اخرى كثيره و مالك
بنويره احراق الناس في الحضائر كما في
طبقات ابن سعد وهذا العنف اللي اتخذها
وحتى الكتابات الغربيه يعني الرومانيه لها
اسهام حول هذا قد يذكرون اشياء عجيبه ونحن
نستغربها الله اعلم لكن في فتنه يعني هو
كل هذا تحت قوله عز وجل احسب الناس ان
يتركوا ان يقولوا امنا وهم لا يفتنون
والدنيا مشكله يعني الدنيا فتنه وحب العلو
في الارض والقصص السابقه في الانبياء بعض
اصحابهم الخلصق يعني قد ينقلبون
قد يتوبون ما يتوبون
يقبل الله توبتهم ما يقبل لهم اعمال تعادل
هذا ما لهم اعمال هذه تحبط ما تحبط كل هذا
موضوع الهي نحن نتحدث في الجانب التاريخي
فقط كما نرى وكما نبحث والله اعلم
بالمالات عند الله عز وجل